CHRIS BROADFOOT: We're
here today for
Maps API Office Hours.
I'm Chris.
LUKE MAHE: And I'm Luke.
And we're from the Maps
Developer Team down in Sydney.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So today we'll
be answering some of
your questions.
Occasionally we'll do some sort
of presentation on some
new features, but today we're
just answering questions.
If we have time, we'll look at
some stackover flow questions,
and we'll go through all of the
ones that you guys have
added on to the Google Moderator
So first of all,
Kieran, have you got
any questions?
Share with us what you're
working on.
KIERAN MCDONALD: Yeah, well,
I've just got the three that
I've posted on the
Google Moderator.
One was just like a airy-fairy
question, and the other two
I've kind of got jsFiddle for
us so you can have a look at
the working examples.
Basically, we're using the
Google API Version 3.
And we've just gotten into using
the KML layer so that we
can take KMLs from clients and
draw stuff over our map.
And we've found that--
it's in the documentation, so
it's still pretty clear.
But your KML has to be public
because the server's getting
KML, doing some stuff and then
sending that to our maps.
So we think it's OK for now, but
there's not a whole lot of
sensitive data in there.
But there might be in the
future, and we're not 100%
sure on it, so we're just
wondering if there's any plans
for that in the future?
LUKE MAHE: Currently no, because
our servers have to
render that data center to be
able to access a KML file,
write it down, and then they
use blank files and send it
down to the browser.
Yeah, we have to be able to
access it for us to be
able to render it.
There's probably a couple
techniques you can use if you
were to make it semiprivate,
where you could essentially
give the user a token that
expires after a certain time
in that CRL that loaded.
KIERAN MCDONALD: That's pretty
much our way around it because
we have the route publicly
accessible and then we just
make the URL like a secretive
URL It'll probably suffice,
but I was just checking to see
if there is any future
uplighting.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so there
is one alternative, and
that's to render everything
client side, where you can
control how it gets sent
to the client.
So if you're running KMLs
specifically, there's a
client-side parser
called GGeoXml3.
And that will go and take
your KML file and
display it on layer.
But everything's rendered client
side, so none of it
will serve as all three
of these sides.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK, so we would
parse the KML and then
add the features using
the Maps API.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
You don't get the benefits of
KML layers, such as being able
to render many, many points
and polygons.
Because it's rendered
server side, it can
be done very quickly.
You've still got
the limits of--
so A, parsing the XML in
JavaScript, and B, adding
Google Maps overlays.
So you come into the
same problems with
adding lots of overlays.
KIERAN MCDONALD: Yeah.
And the problem's probably
not big enough
to worry about that.
We'll probably just
leave it as it is.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Oh, definitely.
You take a look at
GGeoXml then.
That's probably--
KIERAN MCDONALD: So that just
reads the KML, and then we'd
have to use the appropriate
part of the API to
put it on the map?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I can't
really recall.
I think it might even just let
you add overlays directly into
Maps, or it might return you
an array of features.
KIERAN MCDONALD: Cool.
I'll check that out.
Thanks for that.
So the other two had to do
with KML layers as well.
One was to do with just error
handling and connectivity.
So if our servers are
not responding, or--
LUKE MAHE: I haven't looked
at that one that you
posted about yet.
The connectivity, if we also
find one that actually doesn't
exist, it goes to a weird
position in zoom-in.
That definitely looks
like a bug.
We should fix it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, that
sounds like a bug.
But there is a way to get some
sort of idea, client side,
whether the KML layer
has loaded or not.
There's an MVC property
called Status.
So if you listen to
eventstatus_change, you'll be
able to figure out whether--
[TYPING]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: --whether the
KML layer was loaded, or
whether there was some sort
of error, like it
timed out, or not.
KIERAN MCDONALD: Yeah, I guess
we were thinking of doing
something like that, because we
noticed that the properties
were changed.
We were going to look at if it
was zoomed right in and in a
weird position, and then if
it was, then fix it up.
Is this Status Changed thing
something so that you don't
have to get it into that state
in the first place?
Or is it just another thing
like the zoomed-in
state that you can--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I mean, zooming
shouldn't happen.
That's definitely a bug.
But the Status Changed event
would let you maybe display an
error to these--
KEIRAN MCDONALD: Connect.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: --
or possibly retry.
If there was a timeout,
you could retry.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
Does it have a Cancel, so you
can say, hey, actually don't
do anything.
Just leave it as it is, because
it didn't load right?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, sure.
You could just not
do anything.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK, cool.
So that's probably the
advantage of query.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
Because sometimes, if your
server is too slow to respond,
then we just want to go and
render it, so you can try
again for whatever reason.
KIERAN MCDONALD: Yeah, that's
kind of why we wanted to
handle it gracefully, just
in case of that.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
But if you haven't yet, I would
tell you not to bother
with the bugs.
The current one would
be just the pin.
And if nicely done, you include
a jsFiddle example,
which makes our lives
a lot easier.
LUKE MAHE: So actually, file
an issue, and then we'll
follow it up.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
So where do I file that one?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if you go
to the documentation, there
should be a thing on the
side that says Issues.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
Oh yeah, I think I've even seen
on the Maps API, it says
Report a Map Error
or something.
Is that--
LUKE MAHE: Oh.
Report a Map Error is
slightly different.
That's actually report a
data error with a Map.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[TYPING]
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
I'll definitely check out that
Status Changed event.
And the final one was
just some advice.
There's another Fiddle
there too.
So I played around
with Clickable,
setting it to False.
And that solves my issue with
right-clicking on polygons.
But then I can't click
on the layer.
So my thoughts on solving that
was having clickable True,
grabbing the event, and
then re-raising it.
I was just wondering if I was
doing something silly, if I
was going to do it that way.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So the Maps
API, if you're familiar with
the DOM in HTML5, there's no
concept of event bubbling in
the Maps API.
So if you right-click on a
layer, that right-click event
won't be propagated
to the Map below.
KIERAN MCDONALD: That's
something.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, so it sounds
like you've solved it the way
that I think you should
by sort of
bubbling it yourself manually.
KIERAN MCDONALD: You
think that that's a
reasonable thing to do?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, I think so.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
Great.
Well, that's all the
questions I had.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You might
find some lag as well.
When you're right-clicking the
event, you probably won't get
fired straight away.
But when you right-click on a
KML layer, it actually sends
that to Google Service.
So you might see that lagging
network, but it should
function properly.
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
So that's because it's rendered
it on the server
side, and it's also doing
a querying on the
server side as well?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So it basically says what
feature have I clicked on?
It goes and asks the server
that, and then comes back and
returns it.
KIERAN MCDONALD: So if I set
Clickable to False, it doesn't
do all that stuff.
It just renders on the server,
and then that's the end of the
communication?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
You'd usually--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KIERAN MCDONALD: Maybe
one work-around is--
so the only reason I want it to
be clickable is so that if
it has an info text on a
pin, you can see what
the info text is.
Could a work-around
be to put texts--
is there another way of having
a pin and then a text next to
it all the time or is that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KIERAN MCDONALD: OK.
Great.
Thanks for that.
LUKE MAHE: No worries.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Feel free
to stick around.
We'll be looking at some of
the questions that other
people have asked.
KEIRAN MCDONALD: Yep.
Sure.
LUKE MAHE: How should
we do this?
Do you want to go from bottom
to top or top to bottom?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's
go from the top.
LUKE MAHE: OK. "Will Google
Maps/Earth API"--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, this one.
LUKE MAHE: Oh wait.
That one, yes.
Sorry.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You've
got a presentation.
LUKE MAHE: There we go.
Loading.
Cool.
OK. "What is the leanest method
for displaying many
placemarks on Maps with
various metadata?
Loading via CSV, KML,
FusionTables, AppEngine?
By lean, I mean overhead
for device bandwidth."
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Interesting.
So Luke and I wrote an article
about displaying
mini-placemarks on maps.
And you can find that on
the documentation.
If you go to Articles and go
to the "Too Many Markers"
article, we present a whole
bunch of different ways of
handling this.
LUKE MAHE: But really, this
depends on your use case and
what your devices are.
If your user experience is that
I need to see all this
data at the same time, all
zoomed-out, then maybe
KML/FusionTables is a better
approach, because that'll
render all data to tiles.
And it'll be quicker
and less overhead.
If it's more you're querying
by some viewport and you've
got a lot of interaction with
the user, there may be
something like AppEngine with
JSON response that you send
back, and you can just query
in the viewport and display
markers that's just relevant to
what you're currently doing
at the time.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So KML and FusionTables
render server side.
So for many amounts of markers,
you might have, say,
200 markers in one tile,
compared to rendering each of
those 200 markers separately
on the client.
On a mobile device, that
might be very slow.
If we can render it using
Canvas, it might
be reasonably quick.
But if we're rendering 200
different DOM elements as
opposed to one for one tile,
that could be quite slow.
So I'd definitely look at KML
and FusionTables, or possibly
rolling your own tiles.
If the data doesn't change at
all, then you can pre-generate
all of those tiles or even
generate them on the fly.
Yeah.
Cool.
LUKE MAHE: OK.
So that was a KML one.
Try this one, Chris.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So "What is
the proper way to destroy a
map instance?" So this is not
something that we really
designed the API to do.
Generally, we see people create
one map and maybe
destroy it once.
If you're generating maps and
destroying them continuously,
then this is not really a use
case that we support.
It's about that, but it's
something that you probably
shouldn't be doing.
LUKE MAHE: We recommend instead
why don't you keep the
same map object around and
just keep reusing it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So if you need to keep hiding
and showing the map, it's
definitely better to just keep
that map instance around as
opposed to trying to delete it
and create new ones, because
I've looked into this, and yes,
there is memory leak.
So--
LUKE MAHE: But your best option
are to make sure you've
cleared every listener that
you've added to anything that
was on the map.
Delete all the references to
the map object, and you can
even cover the div
in your HTML and
override its inner text.
But some browsers
will still leak.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Pretty much every browser.
LUKE MAHE: Every browser.
We try our best. There we go.
"Best practice for a large
Google Maps project, best use
of APIs with a large number of
markers, example code, or best
practices?"
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Best practices.
This is interesting.
LUKE MAHE: This kind
of relates to
the question before.
It depends on your use case.
What is the experience you're
trying to give to the user at
the end of day?
If it's a lot of data, then
maybe something like KML or
FusionTables.
If there's not much data, then
just markers are actually
really good.
Some best practices are to not
make your marker bounce in if
you've got lots of them.
Because that's individual DOM
elements bouncing in, and then
we write it as Canvas.
Setting Optimize to True,
because again, we'll be
painting it in Canvas instead
of individual DOM elements.
What else are you thinking?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I
guess it depends
what you mean by large.
If you mean large in complexity,
you might consider
using MVC objects.
So MVC objects are a way to
separate your view and your
model to provide a clean
separation between those
concepts, which gives a pretty
nice way of structuring a
large project.
I mean, a large number of
markers, we answered. yeah,
definitely look at that article,
"Too Many Markers."
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
that's if you want to--
if it's just the Maps API, and
then you can do other stuff in
terms of using your JavaScript,
like using the
Closure Library and
the Compiler.
That'll look over your code to
make sure if there's any bugs
or anything that
you can improve
performance in some areas.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
LUKE MAHE: If you have any
specific questions, you can
add them later on
for next time.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess if
you're showing complex
overlays, you might start to
consider rendering those
server side and sending
down tiles.
You can use Image Map type
if you're showing lots
of things at once.
I've seen some pretty cool
stuff with that.
LUKE MAHE: And some other things
that we see as a common
mistake is, a lot of people,
when they're first starting
out will just load every single
marker in the entire
world, and then just send that
down to the browser.
So that's obviously, using JSON
or whatever, it's a lot
of data anyway to send
down to the browser.
You're creating a lot
of markers that
aren't actually visible.
So you can do some stuff by
getting the map bounds and
then querying your service and
say just give me the markers
that are in my bounds, and
then just render those.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: By the way,
if you're watching and you
want to join, definitely--
oh, Leon, I can see you're
trying to join.
I've added you to our circles.
And Yoko as well.
So if you'd like to join, hit
Join Hangout on the Plus page,
and you can come and
hang out with us.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
Next one.
"I'm using fitBounds to fit
all markers to the map.
When I only have one
marker, the zoom
automatically goes to 100%.
How can I fix it?"
CHRIS BROADFOOT: What
does this mean?
LUKE MAHE: It means, so if you
only have one marker with
fitBounds, just that
one marker, and
it's too zoomed in.
What you could do is you could
obviously add an event to
listen for Zoom Changed.
And then when you call
fitBounds, you could either
save it if your zoom is to high
and then zoom out, or
beforehand you could look at--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You can set
the maxZoom property on the
map as well.
LUKE MAHE: You can set maxZoom
ending zoom on a map so you
don't go in too far.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: But really, I'd
just check if you have one
marker, and then choose
a zoom level--
LUKE MAHE: That is
appropriate.
Again, this is really hard,
depending on your use case.
You may want to be
zoomed in far.
zoomed out far.
"Will Google Maps and Google
Earth API v3 allow clickable
3D models as per Google
Earth desktop?"
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I'm not sure.
Luke and I don't really work
on Earth, so I didn't even
know there were clickable
3D models.
LUKE MAHE: If you haven't yet,
file a feature request. We
don't usually talk about what
we are working on or what's
coming down the pipeline, but
definitely file a feature
request for this.
And if enough people want it, we
will look at seeing if it's
feasible to implement.
Chris is moving his laptop.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Ah,
that's better.
Oh.
Leon, how's it going?
Oh, I can't hear you.
I think you're muted.
LUKE MAHE: No, you're
still muted.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I can open up
Chat so you can chat to-- oh,
he's chatting.
LUKE MAHE: Should we
carry on while--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yep.
LUKE MAHE: No mic, dude.
You can do hand signals.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You can
chat to us on the
side, if you like.
LUKE MAHE: And Chris
will read out.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So for people
watching, Leon is our
organizer to the Melvin Google
Technology User Group.
LUKE MAHE: Chris will try and
repeat your question, doing
your voice as accurate
as possible.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I can't
remember what he sounds like.
He's--
we don't have to say that.
Leon's using a Chromebook.
Yeah, my microphone broke
on my Chromebook, too.
I also broke the developer
switch as soon as I got it.
LUKE MAHE: Leon is typing.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So let's go to the next one.
LUKE MAHE: Let's go to this
one, and then we'll answer
Leon's question.
Where are we?
So "will we improve Google
Maps API for Android?
The current API doesn't support
fragments, and it's
difficult to include
it in a fragment."
[INAUDIBLE PASSAGE].
Does that work on the Android
Maps API, the Android team?
We could join one of
their Hangouts.
I hear they do them once a
week, I think, as well.
And you can ask them that,
and they'll have
better answers for you.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
Leon is saying--
oh, here's a better idea
about 3D models.
He says "the person
was referring to
Android and--" ah, right.
Ah, right.
So our buildings
that come out.
LUKE MAHE: Oh, right.
When you're in--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I mean,
again, we can't really talk
about future plans.
But that's something that
I'd really like to see.
Now that we have pretty good
WebGL support, if we can start
getting those 3D models down to
the API as well, that would
be brilliant.
LUKE MAHE: File a feature
request, so we know how many
people actually want it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So Leon says,
"so can we--" wait.
That doesn't make sense, Leon.
"Can we build 3D models
using this?"
LUKE MAHE: That would be cool,
if you could build a 3D model
and throw it into jsmaps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
Let's go to the next one.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So, "will you
improve Google Maps--"
LUKE MAHE: That was
the second one.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: "We've
developed a historical mapping
app using the deprecated Maps
API for Flash and like the 3D
effects for visualization.
Are there plans to enable 3D
effects in the future for
JavaScript v3 API?" Not that
I'm aware of, although it's
certainly possible
with the new 3D
acceleration in browsers.
So yeah, it's definitely
something we
should take a look at.
File a feature request.
LUKE MAHE: That saves a bit--
that should just be the subject
of this thing, "File a
feature request."
TOM: Hey, guys.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hey.
LUKE MAHE: Hello.
TOM: Sorry I'm late.
We got caught up in
a furious meeting.
I just ran over.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So for people
watching, Tom is a developer
here in Sydney.
He's working on GoCatch.
LUKE MAHE: Which is a pretty
cool Android/iPhone app, where
you can find a taxi, and it
will come pick you up.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So they're doing some pretty
cool things with Maps.
We had a look this morning,
had a chat to
them, which is great.
LUKE MAHE: You got any questions
for us, Tom?
TOM: No, I don't actually,
I was just going to--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: All right.
We've lost Tom.
LUKE MAHE: We did lose Tom.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's OK.
He got his two minutes
of fame.
LUKE MAHE: Have we lost
Leon as well?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Is my
laptop not working?
No, see, I've got you.
Oh, Leon's still here.
OK, Leon, you're frozen.
Tom, you're frozen.
OK.
Let's go to the next one.
LUKE MAHE: OK.
Do you want to read
the last one?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: "Will Google
API v3 wrongly change again
streets and location
Catalan's name?"
LUKE MAHE: I think it means that
we've changed the name.
On Maps will it come, and will
it also change in v3?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So the
locations we show in the Maps
API are the same as the ones
on maps.google.com.
So if you ever see a problem,
go down to the bottom right
and hit Report a Map Error.
And there's a really great team
working behind that to
resolve issues.
LUKE MAHE: We should also
mention out here that you can
load the API in different
languages.
So I'm not sure what the problem
actually was, but if
we are showing you an English
version of it instead of
Spanish or Catalonian--
yep?
Good.
The producer just told
me I said it right--
that you can load the API
in that language.
And you will probably see the
tiles in the correct way that
you want them to.
But if it is--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So load with
the Catalan localization.
So Leon's asking about
optimization and lean
techniques.
He says, "the produced case
might be to Glocate user,
create a server with map bounds,
and return some JSON."
So this is a technique described
in that "Too Many
Markers" article.
And yeah, it's definitely
a way to go.
LUKE MAHE: It's quite a common
way to do it, and that's quite
a speedy way of doing it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So you
want to avoid querying
the server too often.
So we've actually solved this
in the API by providing an
Idle event, which basically
tells you whenever the user
has stopped moving the map and
whenever they likely want to
see some updated data.
LUKE MAHE: Another option is
to just listen to the Bound
Change event and
have a window--
[TOM SNEEZES]
LUKE MAHE: Bless you.
But you have a window timeout
that you clear
every time it's updated.
And then if the bounce doesn't
change or a timeout expired,
then that person does your
iaddress period.
And then you can do some nice
things, where you go get your
results back. and maybe
the user's only
panned half a screen.
So you also don't want to get
rid of the markers that are
already on the screen.
So if that person's got a
passion to go, is our marker
already on the screen?
If it is, I don't want to take
it off and put it on because
it might actually be Flash
and other stuff.
So that's sort of a nice
way to improve it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So that's
what we've got.
You guys on the Hangout
now-- oh, Leon's
got some more questions.
"Have you seen any demo apps
with the Places Events API?"
So the Places Events
API is quite new.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
We actually haven't seen any.
But I'd love to see
some, actually.
It'd be cool to see how people
are actually using that.
The problem with the Places API
is, because it's mainly
server side, it's really
hard to demo.
We did have a Places Hangout
last week that is on YouTube,
if you guys want to
go check it out.
It was with Places TL, and they
had some stuff with that.
And Kieran went and
filed a bug.
Good hunting, Kieran.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The engineers
will be happy.
They love bugs.
LUKE MAHE: They do.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So Tom, have
you got any comments?
TOM: Yeah, I'm sorry.
I lost my connection up there.
Yeah I was just tuning
in to see what people
were talking about.
So I don't have anything
specific I didn't talk to you
about this morning.
It's interesting about the
Places Events stuff.
That's a brand new API.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So if you're interested in the
Places Events API, definitely
go back and watch last
week's Hangout.
I think they did a quick run
through of the Places API and
the new Events API.
Essentially people can
check into events--
LUKE MAHE: It's basically
temporary Places, so you don't
pollute your event space with
the events or places that are
no longer useful.
So if there's like South
by Southwest--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LUKE MAHE: --so you don't really
want that line to exist
for another week.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So let's
go over to Steve.
STEVE: Hey, guys.
Hey, I don't really have
any questions.
I was just more kind of
popping in, as I do.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LUKE MAHE: To jQuery or not to
jQuery for the mobile apps.
What are your thoughts?
STEVE: Whoa.
Interesting question.
LUKE MAHE: It is a very
interesting question.
jQuery is cool.
It solves a lot of annoying code
you have to write for a
lot of browsers.
It can get a little
bloated, depending
on what you're doing.
You may have some specific tasks
where jQuery is trying
to solve too much
of the use case.
But generally, I'd say if
you're going to use a
framework, jQuery's up there
with one of the good ones.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
My advice would be to
use it selectively.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
It is about, I think,
107K or something.
I could be completely
wrong, but--
downloading that on a mobile
phone, if you're maybe
somewhere in a country that
doesn't have great mobile
data, that's some time.
STEVE: I think a good use case,
if you're using jQuery
is where you're using it
elsewhere as well.
So like, Doug uses it just
specifically for your Maps.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, totally.
Because if you're using just a
Maps API and most of the stuff
you're doing is essentially
events, the Maps API provides
an addListener and
addDomListener.
And most of time,
people are just
using events and selectors.
So also your modern browsers,
especially in the mobile, have
query selector.
So using that and the Maps API
events, you really don't need
jQuery for a lot of your
stuff anymore.
And then CSS animations
is now remote as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: If you want
the selector engine behind
jQuery, you can use that
separately as well.
LUKE MAHE: It's called Sizzle.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
called Sizzle.
So that's great.
If that and events is basically
all you're doing,
then you can use the Maps
API and Sizzle to--
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
And they also have made
it JSON parsing now.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh.
And Kieran's saying you
can use Zepto as well.
So Zepto is pretty
lightweight.
I think it's under 10K or
something like that.
LUKE MAHE: So yeah.
Again, it depends on
your use case.
If you need everything that
jQuery has to offer and you're
going to use it all,
then go for it.
It's a really great library.
If you don't, then maybe look
at something that only has
what you need.
See, everyone nodding.
Yeah.
I like Node.js.
The Chrome guys love Node.js.
Go talk to Eric about Node.js.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So what
else should we do?
LUKE MAHE: I don't know.
Do you have anything cool
to show people?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I do not.
Not this week.
Maybe next week.
LUKE MAHE: Does anyone got any
suggestions for a theme that
we should do for the next one?
Has anyone been wanting
something really cool, or you
got any really crazy
questions?
STEVE: Did you guys demo OpenGL
or WebGL last week?
Or last month?
LUKE MAHE: No.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I
did a talk at CJS on
WebSocket and WebGL.
So maybe I'll demo that
in the next Hangout.
That might be a bit of fun.
We can do a bit of a--
maybe a visualization-themed
Hangout, something like that?
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
STEVE: Maybe get Anthony and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to show off
some of the crisis mapping.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: All right.
So visualization's
a great topic.
TOM: I wonder if we can get
you some of that data--
[INAUDIBLE  PASSAGE].